If your a guy and your girl seems a little crazy
here's what you can say
No. one “what do you need for me I'm here”
No. two “I'm taking space but I promise I'll be back”
If you’re in a relationship then
you know that you guys don't always agree
instead of acting in the heat of the moment and
you have to walk away
But storming off isn't gonna help either
No. 3 “I'm sorry for X, I'll be mindful next time”
If your partner says something upset them
then you should listen to them and acknowledge it
No. 4 “your thoughts matter to me, tell me more”
it's soo so important that you listen to your partner and they feel understood
No. 5 “I was wrong, how can I make this right?”
So many people apologize for the mistakes they make
but forget to ask for a solution for the problem
No. 6 “I'm on your side”
remember that you guys are a team
so you should be fighting the conflict
not each other
If you’re a man or if you're a woman
Saying these phrases will have a big impact on your relationship
Try this with your partner
if you want a deeper connection!